何のことなくハイハイそういうそういう日本的な考え方ないんです
あなたはあなたの花を持ってこいと
それすごい暗い狭いよ
そういう考え方 だから花を掴む時でも
これはもう自分で自分だけでお供えするっていうことは全く考えていない
初めから例えば明かり
照明ですか 油ですか 油持っていって
まあ高いんだから バジャンというほんのちょっとしか持っていけないんですね
そこで明かり一つ二つに入れたらもう終わっちゃいます
それでも誰か誰かそばにいるなら
じゃああなたもご一緒にとか
もう二人に分けられません
だから大体手でも二人で手でも合わせて
はいはいそこでね それで自分のいい行為をもう一人に分けてあげる
あれであろうか もう何も考えていない
その他にありがとうございますとは言わない
それはもう全くもう関係ない話
すごい欲の世界でありがとうございますと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
あっちではもうごく普通の当たり前のことをしただけだから
そこにありがたいということはないんです
ありがたいなじゃなくて
ありうる話だから あるべき話だから
ですから ありがとうはないんです
ありがとうというのは
本当にそういう個人的に
あの個人の何かもうしてあげたら
もうただ一言葉でありがとうと言って
それはもう終わることはしません
それなりにすごくそれを覚えておいて
いろんな形でいろんな方法で感謝を表す
ですから決まり文句ない
ありがとうとか サンキューとかね
もうすぐ口癖でサンキューなんか言っちゃったら気は割れちゃう
僕はもう遊びに 子供たちいろいろ修行させますからね
なんかちょっとまあ僕のところで英語で勉強したいんだけど
僕すぐもうサンキューとかなんとか言っちゃって
もうかなりやられちゃったんです
子供たちにもうからかわれて
もうどうすることもできなかったんです
で まあ自分がまあまあまあちょっと違う
まあ違うもう世界で育てられちゃったんだから
まあもうそういう癖が本当あるんです
すぐもうサンキューって言ってしまっちゃう
無関心に もう無意識的に
で 今はそういう社会から離れてるんだけど
やっぱりもうこれ 子供たちにバレちゃって
一緒に買い物なんかに行くんですね
まあもうちょっとお手伝いしようってしてもらう気持ちで
で もうそういう口を滑っちゃうんですね
店の人に こちら僕はサンキューと言っちゃうんです
で 子供たちがもうこの顔を見てるんで
もう恥ずかしくなっちゃうな
大体そういう文あんまりないんですね
そういうまあ国民の中ではね
その代わりに心ではちゃんと知ってるんですね
で 例えばこういういいことをすると
他の人を参加させなかったらかえって批判されるんですね
何者か もう全然わかってないんではないか
そんな怒りで 高慢で 自分だけもう良くなりたくてやるのはいいことじゃないんだと
自分だけ天国に行きたくなるということは人を否定することだから
せっかくお金も使って無駄無駄やってるんだと
そういう風に批判までされちゃうんですね
だからやっぱりいいことはみんなでやろうというのがごく普通な考え方なんですね
だからあまりにも当たり前の常識で
大乗仏教みたいにすべての生命のために
すべての生命のためとか
そんなもうなんてスローガンですか
はなし スローガンがあったらそれも怪しいと
なんで当たり前のことをずっと言わなくちゃいけないんですかね
ごく当たり前な人を助けるということ
特別な道徳じゃないんです
それは 人が生まれたら呼吸するのは当たり前であって
人は呼吸するべきですよとかね
看板書いてみてください
あっちこっちで バカバカらしいでしょうね
僕らにとっては 人は呼吸するべきですよとテレビコマーシャルあるように
すごくおかしく聞こえるんですね
この衆生の救済のためにとか
そういうのに笑っちゃったら
あんたは大乗仏教の偉大なるさわかってないやとか
勝手にしろ どうせ僕は頭の中でバカにしてる
もう散々バカにしてるんだから
僕は一人で楽しんでやっちゃう
まあですから この何て言いますか
やっぱりもう一人参加するとどうせ気持ちいいんですね
いいことっていうのは気持ちいいものなんです
で 二人でやるとさらに気持ちいい
3人4人でやるとさらに気持ちいい
それで皆様にも回向の文句を覚えさせてるでしょ
その回向の文句もまあきちんとテーラワーダ的じゃないんだけど
あの まあ書いたのは私じゃないんだけど
ですからね 一応アイデアだけあげて
デーモン書いたんだから
まあでもそちらでもやっぱりちゃんと生きとし生けるものは幸福でありますようにと
だから回向する場合 自分がいいことをしたんだけど
自分が一人で修行したんだけど
この修行の結果はみんなにありますようにと
だから自分が修行してた天国行くならば
そのカルマでみんなおいでくださいと
私は今カルマを持ってるんだから
みんなに分け分けてあげますよと
それで自分のカルマが減りますかというと減れないんです
減るはずないでしょ 心の状態だから
心は広げれば広げるほど
明るければ明るいほどカルマが大きくなっちゃうでしょ
ですから 回向してカルマが減るんじゃなくて
自分のカルマがさらにさらに良くなるだけなんです
大きくなるだけなんです
でも それは正直な気持ちで
本当にみんなにそうなってほしいと
人が苦しんでいるとくがなくてとくがなくていうと
やっぱり私の徳の力ででもこの人は幸福になってほしいというふうに願わなくちゃいけないんです
そういうふうにみんなと心を繋げる
それで回向だけじゃなくて
我々の伝統だったら逆もあります
逆の いわゆる人の道徳を自分でいただくと
それはどんな日本語でいいんですかね
回向っていうのは漢字はおかしいんだけどね
向こうに回すですから
受講でもダメですね とにかくなんか日本の仏教でそれ言葉もないんでしょうかね
もしかするとあるでしょうかと
アヌモーダナというパーリの専門用語がありますよ
アヌモーダナ モーダナというのは喜ぶこと
アヌっていうのはそれによって喜ぶと
人はいい 人々はいいことをしている
修行するは瞑想するは布施するはもう戒律守っているは
いろいろな人を助けているわとか
それを見てすごく素晴らしいんですよと
どんどんやっていただきたいんだと
私にもそのいい行為のカルマの結果がありますようにと
自分もみんなのいいカルマの結果をいただく
そのいただくことも大変いい行為なんです
自分のいいカルマはみんなにあげる
みんなのカルマ自分でもらうと
両方なんです ですから
テーラワーダ仏教のこの
何と言いますか 奉行の次元というのは結構
結構幅 大きい 違うんです
大きいかどうかはわかりませんだけど
大乗とはなかなか違う
大乗というのはすごい西洋的で
自分が人を救ってあげるんだって
それぐらいに終わっちゃいますからね
でも大乗仏教といっても仏教は入ってますから
ちゃんと回向の習慣やらカルマを受ける習慣
そういうのも仏教普通にありますよ
普通の大乗経典の中にもいろいろありますよ
菩薩のパーラミターというパーミット修行といえば
そういうのは全部入ってるんです
入ってるんだけど 全然それは使ってないんですね
まあそれだけのことで
まあ正直に実践すればね
そんな大乗仏教とそういう違い
差がないんです ですから
韓国やらベトナムやらね
台湾やらね 全然差がないんだから
テーラワーダのお坊さんたちももう大乗のお坊さんたちも全然もう仲良くやってるんです
まあ揚げるお経違うだけ
着ている服は違う それは別にもう何も違和感なし
そちらはそちらのお経あげて
こちらこっちのお経あげて
行動は一緒にやっちゃうんです
ですから 僕らの国々ではすごい誤解しているんです
大乗仏教はものすごい仏教であって
もう全くもうただの兄弟二人だけですよと
でも日本に決めたらまたすごい違いますけど
これはもう敵扱いされてる
[笑い] それはそれで置いておいて
とにかくこの まあ天国の話に
話でも余談になる 余計な話になりましたけど
この やっぱりそこではね
たくさん人がいた方がいいんです
いた方が喜びが大きくなる
喜びが大きくなるとそれなりに寿命も長くなっちゃうし
で まあいいことはみんなでやらなくちゃいけないと
みんなを参加させなくちゃいけないと
で まあとにかく悪い心はほんのちょっとしかない
いい心はたくさんある
悪い次元もほんのちょっとしかない
いい次元っていうのはたくさんある
人間がやっぱりいつも悪い次元に回って回っているという
人間だけじゃなく生命
まあその話はそこで終わって
そこで心が 心がいつでも善と不善
それだけですよとは言えません
どっちにもない心があります
それは無因心と言うんです
あの無因心 名前だけ書いて今日終わりますよね
無因心と言います で これは全部十八種類ですね
どんな分け方でしたっけ
アクサラ・ヴィパク で
一番目は不善いじく心
一番目じゃなくて あっちのカテゴリーが
不善いじく心七つ それはもうアクサラ・ヴィパク
不善いじく心七つあります
まあここら辺は一応覚えているかもしれませんだけど
ウペッカー 日本語の漢字も入れましょうか
七つですね 一応あの漢字入れますけど
[背景の雑音]テキストにありますからね
一応テキストからでもノートは取れます
サティはですね そうですね
そういった水道  で はい
じゃあ簡単に説明いたします
不善依熟心だから 人は何か悪い心で行為をしたら結果は受ける
結果を受けるということは
やっぱり心で何か感じるということなんですね
生命は生きてなければカルマの結果が罰が当たったと言えませんだから
ですから やっぱりそちらにも心の問題が出てきて
自分が受ける結果が心で受けるんです
それは心は 7つ ですから
どんな悪いことをしたっても
結果を受ける場合の心は 7つしかないんです
そういうことはすごくわかりやすく簡単といえば簡単なんです
自分がいろんな悪いことを悪いことをすると
7つの心で結果を受ける
それ 7つのことで 1番目は遮後の眼識
眼識 眼どっち？遮後の眼識と
で 遮後っていうのは別に苦しみもない
楽しみもないという中的な感情
感覚なんですね そういう中的な感覚で
目で認識が生まれる 目でものを見る
そこで言いたいのは 目でものを見て
ああ 苦しいということは生まれません
結局どんな悪いものを見ても
どんな綺麗なものを見ても
目の感じは同じなんです
ただ 悪いことをした人はいつでも悪いものを見るようになっちゃう
見たくないものを見るようになっちゃう
だからといって苦しむ必要はないんだけど
人は苦しんでしまうんですね
そこでその苦しみってなくて
この 眼識が生まれるんだと
遮後の眼識が生まれるんだと
いわゆる音は聞く あるいは鼻で香りを嗅ぐ
舌で味を味わう そこまでは遮後なんですね
いわゆる人が悪いことをしたら罰が当たるんだという
そんな単純なことは仏教で言ってないんです
悪いことをした人は悪いところに生まれたら
そこでものは見る 音は聞く
香りは嗅ぐ 味を味わう
それは全部悪いカルマの結果なんです
全部体だから そこで体の場合は苦の心識
体で苦しみを感じる それは違う
眼耳鼻舌身意は まあ射具なんですね
音を聞いて痛くてしょうがないということはないでしょ
痛みは感じません でも気持ち悪い音やら気持ちいい音は別々なんです
だから悪いことした人は気持ち悪い音を聞くだけで
別に耳が痛くても血が流れてるんだということはないんです
見たくない気持ち悪いものを見るようになってるだけで
だからって目が痛いということはない
嗅いだくないすごいキツい
もう香りと言わないね
何と言います 悪臭なんかは嗅いだりするかもしれませんだけど
それによって鼻が痛いということはないんです
体が痛い 例えば悪臭なんか嗅いじゃうと
もうね 胃が荒ばれてもう戻しちゃうわ
気持ち悪くなるわ もう倒れてしまうわ
すっごい敏感なんです
まあそれは個人差あるかもしれませんだけどね
まあ僕なんか鼻がすっごい敏感な
ちょっとでも香りが違う
入ってきたらすぐわかって
体の中いろいろ変化を起こしてしまっちゃう
音に敏感な人いるでしょうしね
それなりに 僕は耳が遠いんだから安全ですけど
[笑い]で 体の場合は苦しみを感じる
その 5つはもう悪いカルマの結果
ですから 例えば悪いことをして畜生
畜生ですか 動物の世界に生まれたんだと
そこで見たり聞いたり
もういろんなことがあったりで
それはもう同じ心で地獄に落ちたっても
その心同じ心ですよ そこで何ですかね
この次に 6番目に出てくるウペッカーサハゲタサンパティッチェナ
これ難しいんです それはこの対象を心で受け取るということなんですね
この入る対象が これちょっと心の働き
眼耳鼻舌身から入る対象は心で受け取る
そこでこれはスウィド
スウィドシンがあります
7番目に スウィドシンの場合は
その何とかのカテゴリーに入れちゃう
あれは嫌なものやとか
いいものやとか もうカテゴリー
これ決まってるんです
聞きたくない音やらいろんなもの出てくるんだから
それは嫌なものというカテゴリーに入れなくちゃいけないんです
そこで聞きたくないというのも
またちょっと違うんです
自分で好き勝手に聞きたくないではなくて
その生命については限っては聞いてはいけないことあるでしょうに
見てはいけないことがあるでしょう
それにやっちゃうんですね
だから命は危ない 苦しみだけ
例えば悪いこと 人間で悪いカルマの人がいるならば
もう人間で食べてはいけないものを食べなくちゃいけない状態になっちゃう
捨てたものやら腐ったものやら拾ったものやらとかね
人間だったらやっぱり清潔なものを食べなければ
もう体が壊れてしまう
でもやっぱりカルマが悪いんだったら
食べてはいけないものは食べなくちゃいけないという風になっちゃうんですね
そういうことだから もう判断
これ判断まではいってないんだけど
悪いものやというカテゴリーに入れなくちゃいけないんです
どうして それぐらいこれは 7つで悪いカルマの結果
そこで次の 8つあります
クサラヴィパークチッタ
もう時間飛んじゃったね
4時になりました  3時半？ 4時まで？ 4時半まで
あ そう [笑い]先生 あの
あの寺の あの寺の子供の癖がついてしまったんです
先生 山口さん 喋ってる日本語は全然わかりませんだけど
ああ そう [笑い]それで
で 次にあるのはクサラヴィパークチッタ
クサラヴィパークチッタは 8つ
で 不善意熟心ではないんです
善意熟心  [咳]で あの
まあちょっと字消しただけなんです
で 腐敗がちょっと で 性成熟心
七つの代わりに八つ入るんです
そこで舎利的の着衣にゃーのと
舎利的の自色と舎利的の比色と舎利的の接色と
苦行だったら腐敗だから困っちゃうね
体で苦しんじゃそれ変えなくちゃいけない
じゃあそれだけ変えましょう
だけども 苦しみの代わりにスッカ入ります
スッカサハガタンカウェリンヤーナ
で スッカは何でしたっけ
じゃあもう全部書いてから
何でしたっけ 喜怒ですね
前とほとんど同じなんですね
で あの 舎利的の眼識と耳識と鼻識と舌識と身識
あ 鼻識 舌識が生まれて
それから体の場合はスッカサハガタン
楽具身識なんですね 体でいいことの結果だから楽しみを感じる
それだけ違う うーん まあね
まあそこら辺はまあもしかするとオーサーとも言ってる可能性もありますけど
またいろいろ問題が私にはありますが
それからこの体に入った眼耳鼻舌身に入った対象は同じく受け入れる
受ける それが舎利的の領受心というんですね
サンパティッチナチット
サンパティッチナでも対象は体に入っちゃう
心に入ってしまっちゃう
それしょうがないんです
領受心 それから入ったものはもうカテゴリーに入れなくちゃいけないんですね
カテゴリーは二つあります
一つは喜怒の随動心 いわゆるいい
いいものを見たり感じたり味わったりすると
それは楽しみに入っちゃうんだよ
楽しいと入っちゃうんです
まあいいと言ったって
普通なものが体に入っちゃったら
まあ普通というカテゴリーに入ってしまっちゃう
いわゆる舎利的の随動心になっちゃうんです
ですからいいことを 人々はまあたまに楽しい感じがするし
たまに普通な感じがするし
苦しみがない それぐらいですね
カルマのいいカルマの結果
この結果はこの前説明したあの 8種類の善信の結果なんです
そこでいい行為をする人は
例えば人間で生まれたならば
ものを見たり聞いたり
味わったりする それはいいものを見たり聞いたり
いわゆるその生命については大変必要なものを味わったり聞いたりする
ただ 人間欲でやりたがったりということでもないんです
ですから 生命は健康的に
まあ生きていられるんです
そこで対象を判断する場合は
まあ楽しいという判断にもなっちゃうし
あるいはまあ普通な判断になっちゃう
大体そうでしょう 大体
まあすごい幸福な問題何もない人々っていうのは
まあよく楽しく生活しているし
からといって 24時間もう楽しいだけってことでもないしね
大体それには普通にいるし
そういう普通 やつになるんですね
体の痛みやら感じるようになっちゃうと
それはもう何かあのカルマの結果になっちゃうんです
いわゆる体のこの認識機能ですか
どうしようもない 生きている間では
それでカルマから逃げられないっていうのはそういうわけなんです
カルマがわからないと言ったって
僕らにとっては別に何でもわからないと言ったって
それはわからないかもしれませんだけど
人間考えてるカルマがバカバカらしいんです
例えば もう外へ出たところで
階段で足を滑っちゃって骨が折ったと
それで私は過去生で何をしたんだから骨が折ったんだ
そう考え そんなことはもうないんです
そういうのいわゆるお釈迦様だけなんで
それはもうあるとあらゆる次元でも能力を持ってるんだから
そこでこのもう海岸の砂の如く行為があるでしょうに
その中からこの砂粒ですよと選ぶぐらい難しいものなんです
我々は常に瞬間瞬間カルマをしているんだから
だからどんな瞬間のカルマで自分の骨が折れたかと聞くの
聞くのはバカバカしいんです
全くわからない だからお釈迦様考えるなと
そんなことは それは逆算でわかりますけど
お釈迦様言ってないんだから
とんでもない迷惑でしょうね
そんなこと聞かれると
人がどれぐらいカルマをするかというと
もう瞬間瞬間もう恐ろしい量のカルマがする
そこでお釈迦様は自分の知恵で人の生命過去を見て
まあここら辺でやったカルマだろうという風な推測も働かせて
あなたは過去生でなんとかなんかの生でもうなんとかなんとかことをしましたから
今の今世でこうなってるよと言わなくちゃいけない
そんなもう無駄使いする暇があるならば
まあ他の何かやればいいし
無意味なことをお釈迦様はやりませんだから
やっぱり悟りに必要な時は
どうしても理解が必要というところだけ
お釈迦様はカルマのことを言うんです
例えば ある人が出てくるお釈迦様の前に
ものすごい特別な性格があると
例えば阿羅漢になるべき徳があったお坊さんがいたんですね
出家したんだけど どうも体が病気なんですね
で まあもう体動かない
あっちこっち まあ何て言いますか
いろんなものできてきて
それはもう化膿して で
筋肉とかね 全部もうそういう風になってきて動かないんです
その上もう出家したんだから
親戚も誰もいないでしょうに
他のお坊さんたちが面倒見てあげなくちゃいけない
お坊さんたちも自分で修行するために出家したんだから
みんな忙しいんですね
誰かもう死にかけてる人の面倒見て自分の人生終わっちゃったら
それはもったいないことないし
それでも面倒見てあげたいんだけど
その人はまたその上性格が悪く
やっぱり他人がやってくれるんだから
またお金でやってくれるわけじゃないし
慈悲でやってくれるんだから
その分もう大変謙虚でありがたく感謝の気持ちでこの看病を受けなくちゃいけない
そうじゃないんですね
それであんまりにももう面倒見切れなくて
あまりにわがままだからみんな放っておいたんですね
いわゆるそれほど責任ないんだからね
誰が見たってもいいことだから
まあ他の人もいるんじゃないかと
他のまあ私はダメだと思って
そういうものも一人になっちゃって
もうものすごく汚くなっちゃって
もう死にかけていたんですね
ですごい臭い あの辺にも近寄ることできない
でお釈迦様はこの人はもうそろそろ死ぬでしょうと
で ただまあちょっとね
比丘たちがいる遊んでいるところをちょっと散歩しようと
遊んじゃと一緒にそこら辺行くんですね
お釈迦様そこでちょっともうちょっとした散歩に行くような形をとって行くんです
まあ本当は狙ってるんです
あっちに行くんだっていうことは
行って ある部屋見たら
なんでこの部屋はこんな汚いんですか
臭いんですかとかね それは厳しいんだからね
綺麗にしなくちゃ そこでこういうことだよと
で そこはアナンタ尊者には早くお湯を沸かしなさいと
お湯を沸かしてお湯を持ってきて
お釈迦様とアナンタ尊者か二人であのお坊さんが綺麗に洗う
お釈迦様は洗ったりして
アナンタ尊者が水をくんであげたりとか
それで衣も全部洗っておいてください
それで全部衣全部また綺麗に洗って
体を綺麗にして それからベッドとか全部綺麗なところに綺麗なベッドに寝かしてあげて
衣はもうちゃんと干してあります
インドですからすぐ干しても乾かしますから
それをまた着させて すごいいい気持ちにさせてあげたんですね
まず 心落ち着いて瞑想もできませんだからね
それをもうお釈迦様が自分の手でやってるんだから
それで 何のことなくそばに座ってお話をしたんですね
それを聞いて そのままね
阿羅漢になったんです
で 亡くなったんだけど
それでみんなもう驚いて
もう大変心配して お釈迦様申し訳ない
どういうどんな叱られるかもしれませんし
またもう大変なことでしょうに
ブッダがね もうご自身のね
ああいう死にかけていた人のもう最後の面倒見たっていうことは
そこでお釈迦様は やっぱりお坊さんが集めて叱ってはなかったんだけどね
やっぱりあなた方には母親も父親も親戚もないんだと
みんな出家してもうこちらで修行しているんだから
お互いにやっぱり心配しなさいと
お互いに兄弟のような感じで
まあ家族のような感じでお互いの面倒を見なさいと
もし病気になっている人の面倒を見るならば
これはブッダ自身の面倒を見ることと同じだよと
もし人々は私のことを心配するならば
病気の人々の面倒を見なさいと
それは私に対するあなた方の尊敬だと思いますよと
そういうふうに それ以上言葉ないんだからね
ですから 患者さんが病気の人が見たら
お釈迦様を見たような気持ちで
これはどこかのもう汚い性格悪い人の面倒見てあげてるあげてるんではないかって気持ちじゃなくて
お釈迦様の生きてるお釈迦様の面倒を見ているような気持ちで
まあ人々の面倒を見なさいと
もう気持ちになっちゃう
そういう道徳なんですね
とにかく そういうふうに言って
それでもなんとなく納得いかない
なんであんなにすぐ悟れるぐらいの能力があって徳があって
パーラミタ完成しているでしょ
そうでなきゃ悟れませんから
中途半端では パーラミタ完成していろんな修行を積んでいて
それでも最終的なところで悟りますから
なんであんな不幸に遭いますかと
なんであんな寿命で そこでやっぱり
あ この人は過去世で何やったかとちょっと教えた方がみんな納得するだろうということが出てくるんですね
そうすると悪いことをしないようにみんなするだろうと
そういう場合は何とか過去生でこういうこういうことをしたんですよとは言いますが
それ以上は今日本のいろんな宗教の方々ね
超能力者の方 すぐあんたはもうこういうことをしましたからと
あんたはこういうことをしてよくおっしゃいますからね
お釈迦様もすごく遠慮したもんだけど
もんですけど で まあまあまあ正真正銘のインチキ嘘を言ってますけどね
みんなそんなわかるわけないでしょ
だから我々はいろんな行為をしている
どんなカルマで今こうなってるかっていうことは
もうそこをあんまりきちんと選べてこれっていう風に言うのは難しい
それあるんです そんなもの
それはもう言いにくい
それをもう海岸に行っても
この一粒の砂でこうなったよというぐらいの難しいことなんです
そこは置いておいて カルマの結果っていうのは
私はここに生まれた 何とかのカルマで生まれた
生まれた時から物は見る
音は聞く 香りは嗅ぐ 味わう
いろいろ体で感触を受ける
それは全部あのカルマの結果なんです
だからカルマがわからない
わからないはある意味で馬鹿馬鹿しいんです
我々は見るもの聞くものは全部カルマの結果なんです
見ていない瞬間ありますか？聞いてない瞬間
体動いてない瞬間 ないんだから
だからほんの 1秒でもカルマから逃げたことはないんです
常にずっとカルマの結果を受けているんです
そこで自分がどんな人生やってきましたかとね
まあちょっと 20年  10年ぐらいちょっと観察してみれば
過去 自分の過去をね それは自分のカルマなんです
これからも同じパターンで行きますよ
変わりません みんないきなり大胆に幸福になったと
なりたいとかね 思っちゃいますけどね
ほんのかすかな変わりがありますけど
やっぱり割り当てですか
それは同じなんです だからバカなことをして失敗して
ひどい目に遭って恥かいた人は
それで本当に気をつけますよと思ったりはするんだけど
またやるんです そういうふうなものなんです
ですから この我々いつでも何か持ってる
なんかずっと変わらない
もう決まってるような
なんとなくこの あの割り当てみたいなものが
それはカルマなんですね
例えば食べる場合でも
まあ好き嫌いっていうのは後からつけるもんですけど
あの もう食べ物なんか好き嫌いが出てきたりすると
自分好きなものしか食べられない
それはその人に もしかすると悪いものかもしれませんよ
例えばよく糖尿病やら高血圧やら
いろんな病気にかかっている人々はいるし
やっぱり脂肪ばっかり
砂糖ばっかり食べたりするし
他のものは食べてください
嫌ですよと それで強引に食べさせちゃっても
やっぱり食べられないもの
やっぱりもう拒絶反応を起こしちゃう
で そうすると自分好きなものばっかり食べる
それでももう脂肪が溜まったりして
血圧が上がったりして
もう糖尿病になったりしてとかね
それはもう明確にカルマの結果なんですね
どうすることもできないんです
ですから いいカルマっていうのは
大体好き嫌いなく もう何でも適当に食べられると
あまり文句言わなくて
そういう人は大体自分の健康は何のことなく
ごく自然に守れるでしょ
ですから いいカルマっていうのは
美味しいものを食えるだけでじゃあ決められません
自分の健康的な体調を維持されるような食べ物は何のことなく食べられるようになると
そういうふうなことなの
音にしたっても 香りにしたっても
体の感触にしたっても
例えばすごい贅沢にこの暖かいとこ
部屋の中に生活する そういうふうなことで
ああ カルマがいいカルマだ
そうは言えませんよ それによって体の抵抗力を失ったりとか
ちょっとしたことで風邪引いてもう肺炎になって死ぬとかありますから
ですから 人間に生まれた限りは
やっぱり寒くなってくる
寒さに適している体 暑くなってくると暑さに適している体とかね
そういう風に自由自在に自然の中に生きていられるのは
人間の次元ではいいカルマなんですね
人間でいながら なんか天みたいにえらいもうとんでもない贅沢
贅沢しようとしている人々いるし
途中で切れちゃうんでしょうね
例えばフィリピンのマーコス大統領とあのなんとかマーコス夫人なんか
もう途中で切れちゃったでしょ
天国作ろうと人の金を盗んでと
そういうのはもうもう人間にいたならば
今も元気でいる 我々の社会を見ても
まあ人にふさわしくふさわしいレベル以上に贅沢する人々は
それは自分の悪いカルマなんです
ただいいカルマだと決め
決めつけられません 毎日すっごい豪華な料理しか食べませんよとかね
それ本当にいい 僕はグルメの人々とか
ちょっとちょっと見たことありますけど
なんか見る限りにはこの人すごい不幸だなと
グルメだからものすごい高級料理しか食べないでしょ
あれはもう体には猛毒なんですね
まあ週一回とかね まあ月二回とかは大変楽しいしね
まあ美味しいものをね
もう食べて それで次の日からは余分食べたんだから
もうその分は食べ物を減らしたりして調整する
調整するならば まあいいカルマだと言えますけど
でも人間の気分はそうじゃなく
そういう風な贅沢食べ物毎日食べたいと
それは僕はカルマはすぐ食べてしまう人か
悪いカルマの人かとどっちかに思っちゃいますね
そこでカルマだから 自分にはどれぐらいものを見られるか
どれぐらいの音を聞かれるかと
それまた決まっているよう決まってますよ
過去のカルマだから ですから
見たいものは 20年で見て終わったら目が見えなくなっちゃうんです
聞きたい音はもう 35
6になってくると もう全部聞いて終わっているならば
それで耳が聞こえなくなっちゃうんです
で なんで年取ってくるとどんどん我々の感覚は鈍感になっていくんですか？だと
カルマがもうその人生においてのカルマはもうそろそろ消えていくんだからなんです
ですから あまり贅沢しないですごく